In English, the word transform is a verb and means a dramatic change. Such as I
saw the cube transform into a unicorn. I won't be using that form, I'll be using
it as a noun, where transform is a mathematical term meaning an operation that
changes the position, orientation, or size and shape of an object. Transforms
are a key part of computer graphics. In these lessons, I'll be explaining how
transforms work. You probably didn't realize it, but you've already been using
transforms in a few of the previous exercises. When you set the position of an
object, you were using a type of transform called a translation. We use
transforms whenever we animate anything, objects, lights, or cameras. We're
going to spend a fair a bit of time on transforms since they allow us to do so
much. The study of transforms for computer graphics is associated with the field
of linear algebra. This field is concerned with vector spaces and is usually
considered a prerequisite for any computer graphics programming course. If you
know a bit about linear algebra, great. Having a deeper and wider understanding
of the subject will help. However, basic computer graphics needs just a few
small bits of theory to get things going. My goal in these lessons ahead is to
teach you the tools you'll need to quickly and effectively be able to control
your virtual world.